auch Karl Lauterbach hat heute einmal
mehr für Furore gesorgt es geht um das
Thema affenpocken lauschen Sie selbst
Kernbestandteil ist dass diejenigen die
infiziert sind sich für mindestens 21
Tage isolieren sollen das soll es eine
isolationsanordnung geben für mindestens
21 Tage ebenso tolles eine strenge
Empfehlung eine dringende Empfehlung für
die
Kontaktpersonen geben die unmittelbaren
Kontaktpersonen und Herr Wähler wird
gleich ausführen wer das genauer ist für
ebenfalls 21 Tage so dass wir mit
Isolation und Quarantäne von mindestens
21 Tagen das früher Ausbruchsgeschehen
in den Griff bekommen können
ja Frau stolze war das jetzt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister oder war das
wieder der
bundesbedenkenträger Karl Lauterbach
ja in diese Rolle hat er natürlich schon
und ich habe auch das Gefühl dass Herr
Lauterbach in dieser Situation Angst
Ängste schürt und bisschen Panikmache
betreibt es ist einerseits verständlich
dass alle Welt aufhorcht wenn wieder von
einem neuen Virus die Rede ist und dass
man damit sofort natürlich verknüpft oh
Gott das wird ja wohl nicht hoffentlich
jetzt wieder so losgehen wie mit Corona
aber man muss sich klar machen dass das
in diesem Fall ein ganz anderer Typ von
Virus ist ganz andere Übertragungswege
ganz andere Infektiosität ganz andere
auch sagen wir mal Auswirkungen von
Erkrankungen und das wo sich
Infektionsketten sehr viel schneller
stoppen lassen weil eben die
Übertragungswege anders sind und wenn
man jetzt einige Fälle in verschiedenen
Ländern aufgefunden hat heißt es noch
lange nicht dass das eine Pandemie ist
und dass man jetzt da irgendwie
irgendwie wieder anfangen muss mit was
weiß ich
lockdowns oder ähnlichen Geschichten
ich finde in den
Interviews vermittelt Herr Lauterbach
leider teilweise merkwürdigen Eindruck
auch von diesem Virus und sagt ja
einerseits dieses Virus ist bekannt es
ist nicht so schlimm und andererseits
sagt er aber ja wir wissen aber nicht
wie sich das Virus Verhalten wird und ob
das dann sozusagen zu einem
menschenvirus wird denn wir müssen uns
klar machen eigentlich ist es ein Virus
das hauptsächlich Tiere befällt in der
die der eigentliche Wirts in Nagetiere
soweit man weiß teilweise können auch
Affen sich infizieren und über Affen
kann es sein dass dann eben auch
Menschen sich infizieren aber weil der
Mensch eigentlich nicht der richtige Ort
ist für die Infektion kann sich das
Virus auch gar nicht so gut übertragen
also Hans Ulrich Jörges Affentheater um
die Affen Pocken mein Eindruck ist das
ist heute bestätigt worden durch
Lauterbach er sucht eine Möglichkeit
eine Brücke zu schaffen zwischen Corona
und Corona im Herbst also das ist ja
jetzt erstmal Sendepause also er ist
nicht mehr eingeladen als sitzt sie mir
ein Talkshows und der hat nichts mehr zu
erzählen er hat vorläufig nichts zu
warnen er hat das killer-virus
angekündigt für den Herbst wer dort
drüber gehen kann er nicht mehr es gibt
nichts anderes als killer-virus und
dieses alles die Ängste davor wieder zu
beleben indem er jetzt über die Affen
Pocken redet und wieder Quarantäne
verhängt und so weiter gilt nur noch
dass eine maskenpflicht verhängt die
macht aber da glaube ich gar keinen Sinn
aber jedenfalls ja ja denke ich mir
alles er sitzt wieder mit Herrn Wieler
da es ist das alte Gespann was wieder
auftritt und dann sage ich ach
Lauterbach lass uns in Ruhe
Parteifreund ja ich weiß auch nicht ob
es jetzt personalisieren sollte auf
Herrn Lauterbach ich weiß mich ärgert an
der ganzen Geschichte ist sie sagen
zurecht es ist offenbar ein
vergleichsweise harmloses Virus die
Verläufe sind nicht sonderlich schwer
die Infektionsgefahr ist beherrsch und
was mich ärgert ich mein Krankheit
gehörten Stück weit zur kondit zu humana
wir haben uns irgendwie in Zeiten von
Corona angewohnt dass niemand mehr krank
werden darf also ich würde mal sagen
wenn das eine beherrschbare Krankheit
ist dann sollte man da jetzt nicht auf
panikmodisch schalten sondern sollte den
Leuten sagen es gibt keinen Anlass ich
übermäßig große Sorgen zu machen wer
Angst davor hat dem sollte gesagt werden
wie er sich schützen kann und dann
braucht man ansonsten nicht mehr Herrn
Wieler jeden Tag im Fernsehen auftreten
zu lassen und der Lauterbach sollte sich
um andere aber bauen baut ihr
Parteifreund Lauterbach so wie es
Hans-ulrich Jörg ist gerade gesagt hat
baut der sich eine Brücke bis zum Herbst
braucht er diese Panik eigentlich als
Modus um überhaupt Politik machen zu
können persönlich zu wenig ob er das so
gewissermaßen persönlich benötigt ich
weiß dass Karl Lauterbach in der
Gesundheitspolitik eine ganze Reihe
vernünftiger Position besetzt in der
Gesundheitspolitik etwa was die
Krankenversicherung was die
Bürgerversicherung angeht das sind
Positionen die mir gut gefallen bei Karl
Lauterbach diese Panik um Pandemien ich
glaube sollte mal ein bisschen nach
hinten schieben da haben sich die Themen
vorknöpfen die ihm eigentlich in der
Vergangenheit auch immer schön im höher
richtig soll er doch mal was sagen
zurück zur Krebsbekämpfung soll er mal
was sagen zur neuen Finanzierung der
Krankenkassen sollte mal was sagen was
die Menschen wirklich
beschäftigt an Krankheiten und an an an
an
Finanzdruck auf ihrem Portemonnaie was
Krankheiten angeht und was die
Auslastung von Kliniken angeht und die
Beschäftigung von Pflegepersonal unsere
gibt so viele Themen aber er redet
umwandel im er kommt davon
nicht im Ministerium nach allem was man
hört er schwört ständig draußen rum und
wir können ja jetzt schon Wetten
eingehen dass er jetzt alle 14 Tage eine
affenbrockenpressekonferenz halten wird
mit Herrn Wähler und die neuesten Zahlen
veröffentlichen werde steht hat die muss
ja gar nicht selber verkünden die kann
ein Staatssekretär oder Herr Wieler
jemand dagegen dass das so kommt
halten Sie dagegen oder glauben Sie dass
es genauso kommt nein ich glaube also er
Lauterbach muss das auch selbst
verkünden denn das Problem glaube ich
und deswegen braucht er auch solche
Sachen er braucht diese Aufregung diese
Dramatik wenn man sich mal anguckt wo er
Lauterbach sozusagen
parlamentshistorisch herkommt ich
erinnere mich immer an diesen lustigen
Mann der erklärt hat dass man sein Essen
nicht so stark Salzen soll irgendetwas
jedenfalls
den Menschen Vorschriften machen kann
wie ich wahrgenommen werden kann wie ich
irgendwie ein bisschen wichtig bin und
das versucht er da jetzt gerade meines
Erachtens ganz deutlich noch einmal in
der Tat zur Frage übertragungsfähig
haben sie ja gerade schon was gesagt es
ist einfach also ein vollkommener
Kokolores und ich glaube er ist langsam
einfach an dem Punkt an dem man merkt
dass er ja irgendwie egal wie weit er
dann noch Bewegung reinbringt nicht mehr
noch mal einmal hoch drehen kann und das
führt zu einem überdrehen und dieses
überdrehen merken wir glaube ich gerade
bei dieser Panikmache er macht sich nur
noch lächerlich ich glaube auch dass
eventuell natürlich auch jetzt mit
diesem Thema Viren mit dem Thema
drohende Pandemie Ausbreitung also das
wird ja schon so ein bisschen gezeichnet
als könnte sich das jetzt noch ganz
stark ausbreiten wenn man jetzt keine
drastischen Maßnahmen ergreift also das
hört man schon auch raus und
man kann damit sozusagen auch eine eine
Stimmung natürlich schaffen in der
Bevölkerung und vielleicht das ist jetzt
aber sozusagen Spekulation ist es kein
Zufall dass gerade diese Woche sich auch
Herr Lauterbach mit vielen anderen
Experten wo es um globale Pandemien geht
also globale Infektionserkrankungen
treffen sich in Genf zur
weltgesundheitsversammlung wha und da
geht es unter anderem auch darum der WHO
größere Befugnisse irgendwie zu erteilen
um dann sozusagen Vorgaben für die für
viele viele Länder auf der Welt zu
machen wie man dann mit
infektionsausbrüchen umgehen soll und
das kann natürlich schon auch sozusagen
noch mal Rückenwind für diese ganze
Thematik geben also ich halte Herrn
Lauterbach weniger also er ist in meinen
Augen weniger ein Mediziner dem es
Gesundheit und Patienten um Gesundheit
einer ganzen Bevölkerung geht sondern er
ist ein Politiker der genau weiß welche
Knöpfe man drücken muss um sozusagen
sich ins in den Vordergrund zu spielen
und bestimmte Themen zu setzen und dann
auch politisch was zu erhalten doch viel
interessantere Themen mit denen er sich
in den Vordergrund spielen kann ich
glaube die Leute haben sind dieser
pantologie und es sind dem dem Thema
Pandemie etwas überdrüssig ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass er damit wirklich
Brownie points gibt es gibt viele Leute
zutrifft bei dem Thema
also wenn es zutrifft was gegenwärtig
stand der Erkenntnis ist es ist kein
besonders bedrohliches Virus
Infektionsgefahr ist begrenzt und
Verläufe sind milde in der Regel und ich
sag mal der Kreis der gefährdeten ist ja
auch überschaubar dann würde ich sagen
ich glaube die Leute würden sagen da
wird Panik gemacht wird sind wir haben
genug davon wir haben jetzt zwei Jahre
mit einer Pandemie gelebt
ich glaube nicht dass das dass man sich
als Politiker damit beliebt machen kann
ich glaube noch nicht mal dass ich
glaube
Karl Lauterbach war ja über Monate der
beliebteste Politiker Deutschlands und
im wöchentlichen Insa Ranking für Bild
stürzt er gerade zu ab wann
ist das was er macht eigentlich jetzt
geht das an dem was komplett vorbei
nicht aussprechen man muss sonst
Internet gucken dann sieht man was die
Leute von ihm halten die Kritiker von
ihm halten
kann ich nur vorsichtig sagen wir halten
ihn für für nicht stabil für nicht
gesund muss mal so zu auszudrücken er
ist genauso abgestürzt übrigens wieder
Kanzler und ich glaube dass Lauterbach
das auch erkennt und keine Pause was
seine eigene Person angeht inszenieren
will dass man mal irgendwie ein zwei
Monate nichts von ihm hört weil es auch
nichts zu berichten gibt und er bleibt
mein Ministerium und arbeitet an der
Sache ich glaube er hat ein bisschen
Angst davor dass Panzer nach den
schlechten Wahlergebnissen der SPD
versucht sein könnte die
Verteidigungsministerin und ihnen
auszuwechseln weil sie beide reif sind
dafür ob Scholz dafür den Mumm hat und
die Weitsicht das möchte ich bezweifeln
aber gut wäre es eigentlich müsste er
sich doch freuen das ist mit Frau
Lambrecht noch jemanden im Kabinett gibt
die eigentlich noch viel stärker
davor steht Entlassung zu werden als
Keller Lauterbach oder nicht
ich glaube
das ist das ist die Situation mit den
mit den Mäusen die da irgendwie
versuchen aus dem Loch zu kommen die
eine krabbelt auf die andere drauf das
nützt ja dann letztlich keiner von
beiden ich glaube nicht dass es darum
geht dass irgendjemand da noch
schlechter ist sondern das Kernproblem
von der Lauterbach ist eben halt das
eben einerseits das Thema fehlt das
genug andere Themen da liegen sie haben
es richtigerweise angesprochen aber das
Problem dass er hat ist dass die
Probleme die neu entstanden sind nehmen
wir eben halt die Vielzahl von
ausgefallenen Operationen zum einen
nehmen wir die weitere Überlastung des
Personals im Gesundheitswesen das nur
unmittelbare Folge der
einrichtungsbezogenen Nachweispflicht
ist weil viele hundert Kräfte in jeder
Stadt in jedem Bundesland jeweils
ausfallen und dadurch also die
Versorgungslage noch schlechter wird
Operationen verschoben werden müssen
auch natürlich in der ganzen
lockdown-phase für die er Lauterbach ja
auch mitverantwortlich war weil Teil
dieser Koalition in dieser ganzen
lockdown-phase was allein an Dialyse zum
Beispiel ausgefallen ist verschoben
werden musste was an notwendigen
Eingriffen ich hatte es damals im
Parlament angesprochen an
Herzoperationen für Kranken musste die
verstorben sind da brauchen wir eine
Evaluation